welcome back to las vegas now do you
remember reading national geographic and
just wishing you could jump into the
pages well now you can rocky is live at
rarely seen the new immersive exhibit at
valleys what rare photo are you inside
of now rocky
oh i cannot wait to show you this
because we're not just inside one rare
photo we're inside three okay so let's
see what's coming up now i think this is
going to be because there's three that
you can choose from and then one just
pops up randomly so let's see which one
comes up
it's the penguins i was hoping for this
one mackenzie tell us where we are at
right now so we are in the textures
theme so now right now we're walking
through the textures photographs and
this is the king colony which is the
king penguins i mean if you look at the
amount of these penguins you can only
imagine just being there in person yes
and you can see there's some benches
here so you can sit down and really just
enjoy and listen to the sounds and it's
just it's a beautiful experience so
let's step out outside of this area
into more incredible photos of national
geographic and i have to ask you
mckenzie you know how does national
geographic curate these experiences for
their different locations i think that
national geographic being the brand that
it is is lucky enough for all the
photographers to kind of bring forward
their photos but then they get to pick
and they get to place them all together
like these packaged pieces and rarely
seen as one of those and we're lucky
enough to showcase it here it's so
beautiful and we're seeing a lot of the
environment and you know earth shots and
what else what more can you enjoy here
besides you know those beautiful earth
photos i think what you're going to find
here is actually probably your bucket
list in photo form oh my god is the best
way to put it these are moments in time
but not only that they're places that
you can go and see and feel and come to
bally's and see it first and then you
know start writing that bucket list
yourself that's what i love about
national geographic because it's not
just picturesque it's not just visual
it's an educational experience you guys
are learning something when you come
here so you know like for example we
could read you that we were in the king
colony in antarctica but also there's
some people um displays as well where
people can kind of look through and see
that's right what we're hoping to do is
kind of you to find hidden treasures in
every moment within this spend time with
us but also spend time with these photos
and really see the detail and level of
effort and work that went into them well
speaking of hidden treasures look at
this place you guys let's sit down
mackenzie let's share bean back and just
chill out vibe out here because i feel
like that is what this room is for can
you tell us where we are we are in um
sorry i don't recall the name of it but
um yeah but we are in our lantern room
and this is where it truly transcends
you into the final photo of the
exhibition and kind of gives you a
moment to meditate on what you just saw
oh meditate is the word i'm ready
actually to do that right now so um how
can people get tickets to come see
please visit us at ixvegas.com and or
visit us at the bally's box office okay
thank you mackenzie i will send it back
to you guys